lisa what's going on good morning how
can i help so i have a 16 year old son
who is doing his schooling virtual
at home right now they actually had the
option to go back two days a week
but i wasn't quite sure how the
protocols were going to be
you know of course they tell you how
it's going to be but you know until you
experience yourself
so i just went ahead and kept him home
he's doing really good in most of his
classes
but there's always one class each
semester that he's fallen behind
in and he claims that he's just it
he's bored with it it doesn't interest
him
um and i'm just wondering if maybe if he
were actually
in class and having to see that teacher
face to face
if that would have potentially
made it better for him so i'm just just
kind of wondering if i made the right
decision they're not sending them back
or if there's some other things i could
do to help him he's really into video
games so he
he wants to actually be a video game
program or create video games
when he gets older so you know the
pre-calc that he's failing right now
just doesn't interest him oh so he's
struggling pre-cal
he is um he's a sophomore in high school
he's um
he's a sophomore in pre-cal yeah
ever since elementary school you know
he's been he's been ahead he's been in
honors classes or
been taking high school classes in uh
middle school so
he has the potential it's just the want
yeah
um so are you not sending him back
because
of your concern about his health
um he actually you know i i talk with
him about it i don't just
make the decision i also include what
what he feels because you know in this
uncertain time with the virus
you know i would feel terrible if i sent
him to school and then he got sick
so we we did discuss it we did discuss
it and he said well
i think until we get you know a vaccine
because you know the teachers at that
time hadn't been vaccinated
uh vaccinated as well so they have been
now
um but of course he can't go in in the
middle of the semester and change it up
to uh
partially virtual oh so he couldn't go
now he couldn't
if you decided i'm gonna send him in he
couldn't go i i don't know i would have
to look into it i don't think so but
you know i can certainly look into that
so
i'll give you i'm going to tell you
not a medical answer i'm going to tell
you what i've done in my own house and
then give you some
some broader context okay and then
interestingly i struggled with one class
in high school
and that was pre-cal and it was
a and i i'm now i'm old and i've got two
phds right so it's not an indicator of
how
dumb somebody is as you mentioned it's
it was a hundred percent want to
um some of it was foundational i had
skated through my early
math classes and i hadn't really spent
the time learning
the the constructs there because i could
get by on the tests right
and some students who can test well or
can float through some of those things
end up missing some of those
foundational
concepts and then pre-cal man it it
separates the the sheep from the goats
right
and if you don't have a history of
algebra you have a history of some of
those
that linear thinking man it can be
really challenging
it was a hundred percent want to in my
case right
right and what ultimately got me around
the bin was i couldn't play if i
couldn't pass
and you're talking about it i never i
didn't get seized the first sea i ever
got
was in pre-cal and it was
the war of 1812 in my house when that
happened and so
the other thing is is i my wife and i
man we are as cautious as can be and um
i've stayed on top of the data as much
as i could the decision we made in our
house
was the pros far outweighed the cons
about keeping the kids out of school so
i actually put both
kids are back in school and um
we're a cautious family we just are and
some of our friends think we're
comically too cautious
um but the benefits of the
the science on the kids being out of
school just hasn't been backed up by the
data
so um if there's a chance i i won't tell
you what to do i'm gonna tell you what
we did in our house okay
when it comes to um
that that messy situation that you're in
which is you got a kid that clearly has
the
academic capability right he can do it
and
he's got that things that he loves to do
and then when he loves to when he gets
lasered in
he can knock him out of the park right
and he really has something that he
loves which is video games
and he has something that he thinks he
wants to do someday which would be a
video game programmer
and then he sloughs off one class those
to me are actually
easier to deal with because you're not
dealing with a a
capability issue it's just a want to and
that's when
mom and dad and child can have some
pretty simple
consequence and um decision consequence
actions
or conversations right so right you get
your
you get your precal done which means you
have to put extra time in
and then you get this video game box and
if you don't you don't it's pretty
simple
and what i love to do with young people
is make sure they understand
a hundred percent of this is their
choice
they get to choose in or they get to
choose out
right that's it it's simple and if you
want to
choose to have access to this video game
thing then you're going to
choose to knock this stuff out of the
park and then
it they just get to own that and they
more importantly they get to own the
consequences of it right
the one thing i want to make sure you do
is don't weaponize connection
the other thing i want to make sure you
do is
covid does not mean no boundaries
all these kids are so exhausted and they
are fried and they are
have had to create alternative ways of
living
right and so as a parent i've found
myself
just being like ah it doesn't matter ah
doesn't matter and it super does
because when the boundaries at home
start falling apart too and then it
becomes add to stay up whatever do
whatever you need to do it's just this
one class
they are begging for some semblance of
normalcy some semblance of boundary
and that falls on us as the parents
right so
when you tell this really smart bright
good young man of yours hey you gotta do
you gotta pick it up in precal what's
the response what does he say
uh well many times he will say that he
didn't see the assignment
um which you know that's inaccurate
right
yeah well and and i mean i can
understand
because they have so many different uh
platforms that they get this information
from
but if i can access it i know he can
well and he's
he's a gamer he can see somebody in call
of duty shooting him
from eight screens over upside down
right
he can get that info right yeah it's
it's definitely a want
a
i think you know being being back in
school right now for kids is
the best thing as long as it's safe
that's right and
i think if if he had to face his teacher
rather than facing
me with an answer i think he would step
it up a bit
well and if you're not able to if you
all choose to not put him back in school
if you're
if you're unable to put him back in
midstream
i think that i want him to have that
same relational connectivity with you
right and so it's important for parents
to never weaponize that connection
right you're not going to take away your
morning breakfast with him you're not
going to take away
time y'all spend together he just loses
something of significant value he's got
to feel that pressure
right he's got to feel that boundary
that he chooses
right and so if you choose to not go
find this assignment and make sure you
are a hundred percent
caught up and not only 100 caught up but
you're doing the work
then you are choosing directly not even
as a byproduct you are directly choosing
you're telling us as a family unit i
don't want to play video games
i don't want to be connected with my
friends through technology in these ways
right that's cool you're choosing to
hang out with mom and dad and do puzzles
tonight because also you can't just go
plug hole up in your room either
you are choosing to um
have a lip sync competition with me and
your other brothers and sisters and your
dad in the living room instead of
playing video games
we love that you made this choice it
probably would have been a lot better
for your heart and soul to have done
your precal homework because now we're
gonna record this uh
lip sync contest whatever whatever the
thing is right so
your job is to help him be encouraged
and to set up those boundaries firm and
strong
and his job is to make sure that he
lives into those boundaries and that he
understands choice he understands
consequence and then he gets to make his
deal right
if he chooses to fail man
that's going to be really hard because
there's going to be some really strong
consequences there
if he chooses to disrespect his teacher
in his class by
not going to check out what the
communication is man that's hard
if he can get back in class and y'all
think that's a good idea for your family
awesome i think that's great but at the
end of the day he can choose to fail all
high school kids can
and it must cost him dearly right and
this is going to be hard because it
falls
on you it falls on me it falls on us
parents
and wow this has been a season a hard
season of trying to find the right thing
to do right
so i appreciate your heart for whatever
it's worth
if he doesn't like pre-cal and he
struggles with it and it beats him
upside the head a little bit and he has
to learn some hard lessons
he can still be successful you're
looking at a guy that had that exact
same trajectory so
good for you for caring about him lisa
i'm grateful that you're out there in
the world and in the community loving
your kid the way you are
and um tell him to give me a call i'd
love to talk to him just see how he's
doing
and i haven't had any high school kids
on the show yet so tell them to give me
a shout and we'll talk about pre-cal
i'm not going to be able to help him
with it but we can talk about it that'd
be great